just want to bring you now a statement
from the metropolitan police
on the disorder at wembley on sunday the
final of the european
championships between england and italy
they have said ahead of the final police
commanders deployed one of the most
significant
and comprehensive policing plans the met
has ever committed
to a football match of this scale in
wembley
soon into the day it became clear that a
high number of fans were arriving
without
tickets police commanders recognized
this could result in ticketless fans
attempting to get into the stadium
they updated security officials at
wembley of this risk
to support the stewardig efforts further
highly trained public order officers
were deployed to wembley stadium as a
precaution
statement goes on to say soon after
gates opened the stewarding and outer
security perimeter became overwhelmed
and fans began pushing through security
checks i want to praise the quick
response by police commanders and those
brave officers
who confronted these subsequent scenes
of disorder and violence
i am in no doubt that their swift action
prevented any further escalation
frustratingly 19 of our officers were
injured during the course of sunday's
policing operation
when confronting volatile crowds i do
not accept that the policing operation
failed and i stand by the difficult
decisions made by police officers
and the mets public order commanders
without their immediate intervention it
is possible that this game
could have been abandoned the ugly
scenes at wembley on sunday night will
rightly be reviewed by the football
association
and by police where lessons can be
learnt we will work with partners to
ensure that future
matches are not disrupted by a group of
hooligans
who are fueled by alcohol that is a
statement issued on behalf of the
metropolitan police on that disorder
at wembley um possibly the key line
there is that they do not
accept that the policing operation
failed and you're seeing their scenes
from wembley
on sunday evening